[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen zu gut 20
Minuten Nachrichten und auf den Sport
schaut Norbert Lehmann einen schönen
guten Tag
CDU auf Kurssuche die Partei kann kaum
von der Unzufriedenheit mit der
Ampelkoalition profitieren die AFD
dagegen ist im Aufwind
Vorwürfe nach flüchtlingskatastrophe
Griechenland streitet darüber ob die
Küstenwache das Bootsunglück mit vielen
Toten hätte verhindern können
und angespannte Stimmung beim DFB-Team
nach durchwachsenen Ergebnissen stehen
die deutschen Fußballer gegen Polen
unter Erfolgsdruck
[Musik]
viel wurde innerhalb der Bundesregierung
um das heizungsgesetz gerungen oder auch
sonst machen SPD Grüne und FDP immer
wieder durch Streit von sich reden so
gibt die Ampel in der öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung kein gutes Bild ab nach
einer Umfrage des ZDF politbarometers
sind 54% der Meinung dass die
Bundesregierung ihre Arbeit eher
schlecht macht so negativ ist dieses
Bündnis bisher noch nicht beurteilt
worden davon können aber cdu/csu nicht
profitieren nur 26 Prozent glauben dass
es eine unionsgeführte Bundesregierung
besser machen würde fast die Hälfte
sieht da keinen Unterschied
wie das auf dem kleinen Parteitag der
CDU in Berlin diskutiert wird wie die
Friedrich Merz ist Gastgeber in der
eigenen Parteizentrale alles eine Nummer
kleiner als sonst die CDU muss sparen
als Oppositionspartei man will ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm erarbeiten und sich
hier natürlich gründlich am politischen
Gegner abarbeiten vor allem an der
heizungspolitik der Ampel
diese Regierung ordnet an reguliert
verbietet bestimmt und macht damit etwas
kaputt was wir eigentlich in diesem
Lande mehr bräuchten denn je nämlich
eine Bereitschaft wirklich etwas für die
Umwelt zu tun den anderen politischen
Gegner nennt märz nicht beim Namen die
AFD
es wird für uns weder im Europaparlament
noch im Deutschen Bundestag noch in
irgendeinem Landtag in Deutschland eine
Zusammenarbeit mit dieser Partei geben
es wird sie nicht geben
dafür gibt es viel Applaus doch es
geistern zwei andere Fragen durch den
Raum warum kann Friedrich Merz sein
Versprechen nicht einlösen die AFD zu
halbieren und warum profitiert die CDU
nicht von den schlechten ampelumfragen
diese Fragen treiben die Partei um und
auch in zwei Lager auseinander
inhaltlich wie rhetorisch
es geht darum entsprachlich zuzuspitzen
um damit eben auch Menschen aufmerksam
zu machen sie sind wir haben eine
politisierte Bevölkerung wie noch nie
ich glaube nicht dass es richtig ist
gegenüber der AFD und denjenigen die im
Moment der AFD ihre Stimme geben würden
sozusagen im Ton die Menschen stärker
anzusprechen ich glaube auch nicht dass
es zielführend ist wenn man sich über
Themen unterhält die für die Menschen
eher nebensächlich gesehen werden
ordentlich Arbeit für den
Parteivorsitzenden diese
unterschiedlichen Positionen
zusammenzubringen
und dazu haben wir auch ein aktuelles
ZDF Politbarometer die Zahlen hat wie
immer Matthias vorne für uns guten Abend
wie kommt es bei den Befragten an dass
die CDU eine Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD
ablehnt der cdu-partei Chef Merz ist in
diesem Punkt zuletzt sehr klar gewesen
und das finden die meisten auch richtig
71 Prozent der Befragten sagen es ist
gut dass die CDU jede Zusammenarbeit mit
der AFD ablehnt 25% finden das nicht gut
vor allem die Anhänger der AFD
wir schauen aufs Kräfteverhältnis der
Parteien wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl
wäre können wir die SPD auf 19 Prozent
minus 1 im Vergleich zur Umfrage vor
drei Wochen
cdu/csu 28 grüne 16 FDP 6 die AFD kommt
auf ihren bislang höchsten Wert im
Politbarometer 18 Prozent plus 1 linke
unverändert 5 und warum ist die
Unzufriedenheit so groß da gibt es
tatsächlich mehrere Gründe Streit in der
Koalition schlechte Noten für
Spitzenpolitiker inhaltlich die Sorge
ums Klima aber bei konkreten Maßnahmen
gibt es da auch Skepsis die
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen gehen zu weit
finden immerhin 37 Prozent 22 Prozent
sagen es ist gerade richtig so
35% gehen sie nicht weit genug
große Meinungsunterschiede auch bei der
Frage ob der Westen die Ukraine
militärisch unterstützen soll noch
stärker finden 32 Prozent 40 Prozent
sagen es ist gut wie es ist und 21
Prozent wollen weniger militärisch
unterstützen in Ostdeutschland sind es
sogar 35 Prozent die das so sehen
bei heute
um 19:30 Uhr in der ZDF heute-app und
auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
der Krieg in der Ukraine stellt die NATO
von neuen Herausforderungen
Generalsekretärs doltenberg drängt jetzt
auf höhere verteidigungausgaben der
Mitgliedstaaten 2% der
Wirtschaftsleistungen müssen künftig die
verbindliche Untergrenze sein im Moment
sind die zwei Prozent noch ein Richtwert
Deutschland verfehlt ihn seit Jahren wie
viele andere Länder auch über die
Beratungen der
nato-verteidigungsministerin und
Minister Florian neuer
er könnte sich zurücklehnen im Sommer
endet offiziell die Amtszeit von Jens
Stoltenberg doch dennoch
Nato-Generalsekretär macht was er immer
macht mahnen drängen fordern in westing
in unsere Sicherheit und abstreckung zu
investieren das ist wichtiger als jemals
zuvor ich erwarte dass die NATO
Alliierten sich auf ein ehrgeizigeres
Ziel verpflichten mit zwei Prozent als
einem Mindestwert nicht mehr nur als
Ziel
zwei Prozent des Bruttoinlandsprodukts
für die Verteidigung auszugeben auf
dieses Ziel hatten sich die NATO-Staaten
2014 geeinigt doch nur acht der 31 NATO
starten übertreffen heute diesen Wert
die Mehrheit liegt teils weit darunter
derzeit auch noch Deutschland
weshalb der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister bei der
Verschärfung erst mal bremst
und ich bin auch der Auffassung dass
zwei Prozent sie sollten erst einmal
alle erreichen das gilt auch für uns
dauerhaft erreichen und sicherstellen
das wird für die meisten
Volkswirtschaften nicht von jetzt auf
gleich erreichbar sein die Stimmung in
der NATO aber scheint eine andere von
einer breiten Zustimmung für ein höheres
Ziel spricht der
US-Verteidigungsminister
Länder müssen in ihrer Verteidigung
investieren ich denke wir wissen das
bereits
die USA drängen möglich dass sie dabei
weiter auf ihn setzen können weil sich
die NATO-Staaten auf keinen Nachfolge
Lösungen einigen können gilt Jens
deutenberg als Favorit für eine erneute
Verlängerung als Nato-Generalsekretär
und die NATO konferiert nicht nur in
diesen Tagen trainiert sie auch in
großen Stil beim Luft warfen Manöver er
die Fender über Deutschland sind
hunderte Flugzeuge im Einsatz so
Halbzeit der Großübung schaute jetzt
doch Olaf Scholz vorbei vom Kanzler im
Kampfjet berichtet Thomas Reichert
eine Sache lernt Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz gleich zu Beginn seines Besuchs
in Jagel für einen Kampfpiloten wäre er
leider zu klein ins Cockpit eines
Eurofighters darf er trotzdem und bleibt
lange Sitzen Kanzler im Kampfjet bei der
Luftwaffe können sie sich nicht erinnern
dass es sowas schon mal gab er Defender
ist auch an der Stelle ein Signal an
Russland und eine Warnung
dass wir
Landes- und Bündnis Verteidigung
miteinander trainieren damit wir jeden
Zentimeter des da Donald Tornados über
ihn hinweg dass wir Landes- und
bündnisverteidigung trainieren damit die
Aussage auch ernst genommen wird von
allen dass wir bereits in jedem
Zentimeter unseres Territoriums zu
verteidigen das ist wichtig 25 Nationen
sind bei dem Manöver dabei allein die
USA haben 100 Flugzeuge über den
Atlantik verlegt und an diesem Tag auch
einen Senator den replikaner schon durch
Mann es ist ein Zeichen des Rückhalts
die Piloten üben gemeinsame Angriffe auf
fiktifizielle oder deren Verteidigung
Training und Zusammenspiel sind
entscheidend
Fußballmannschaft die sich jetzt zum
ersten Mal trifft aber so ist es halt
gerade nicht dadurch dass wir natürlich
standardisierte Verfahren haben die wir
anwenden und dass wir auch regelmäßig
zusammen trainieren ist es halt keine
uneingespielte Fußballmannschaft aber es
ist vielleicht eine die jetzt ein paar
Wochen nicht mehr miteinander trainiert
hat Flug Verspätungen wegen des Manövers
waren bislang überschaubar scholz sagte
sei dankbar dass ich bislang niemand
ernsthaft beschwert habe in der
Bundesregierung gilt er Defender auch
als ein Test für die Zeitenwende dafür
wie viele Einschränkungen die
Bevölkerung bereit ist zu tragen
und auch heute wieder Luftalarm in
vielen Landesteilen der Ukraine aus der
Hauptstadt wurde der Beschuss mit
russischen Raketen und Drohnen gemeldet
nach ukrainischen Angaben wurden
mindestens sechs Menschen im Kia vor
Umland durch Trümmerteile verletzt
zeitgleich besuchten mehrere
afrikanische Staatschefs die ukrainische
Hauptstadt sie wollen eine
Friedenslösung ausloten morgen will die
Delegation in Russland Präsident Putin
treffen
ob die ukrainische Gegenoffensive
erfolgreich ist darüber machen Moskau
und Kiew unterschiedliche Angaben in der
Region saporicia haben ukrainische
Truppen die Besatzer nach eigenen
Angaben auf einer Linie von mehreren
Kilometern zurückgedrängt die Stadt
saporicia war vor dem Krieg die sechs
größte Stadt des Landes viele Menschen
dort suchen nach Normalität obwohl schon
wenige Kilometer entfernt die Front
beginnt
während die Männer an der Front kämpfen
sind es die Mütter Frauen Töchter die
versuchen von saporisha aus zu
unterstützen in der Hilfsorganisation
von Ludmilla pecorina besorgen Sie
Medikamente knüpfen Tarnnetze fünf
schaffen Sie an einem Tag 170 sind
bestellt Ludmilla selbst hat vier Söhne
an der Front gestern hat mich einer
meiner Söhne angerufen in dem Moment
habe ich in der Nähe eine Explosion
gehört ich habe gesagt wir hören auf
mache jetzt was du zu tun hast ich will
dich nicht stören bis zum nächsten
Morgen habe ich nichts mehr gehört so
geht das für viele Angehörige schon seit
Kriegsbeginn 2014 die Organisation gibt
den Frauen halt erzählt Ludmilla gerade
jetzt wo die Offensive gestartet ist
welche Mutter könnte sich jemals daran
gewöhnen jeden Tag mache ich mir sorgen
jeden Tag warte ich auf gute Nachrichten
viele Menschen in saporisha wünschen
sich natürlich Erfolge fürchten aber
auch um das Leben ihrer Liebsten die
dort kämpfen die Front ist von hier
nicht mehr weit
saporisha ist eine Großstadt vor dem
Krieg lebt mir über 700.000 Menschen
aber auch jetzt ist hier noch leben
obwohl es Luftlinie bis zu aktuellen
Front nur 40 km sind
in der Stadt bemüht man sich um
Normalität wenn kein raketenalarm ist
sind die Geschäfte auf Soldaten kommen
für ein zwei Tage Pause zum Luftholen
ich habe früher viel darüber gelesen wie
das Leben während des Zweiten Weltkriegs
war und das Menschen einfach in
Geschäfte und Cafés gegangen sind und
mich gefragt wie ist das möglich ist ist
doch Krieg aber genauso ist es jetzt
auch
so steht auf Plakaten in der Stadt wir
haben keine Angst
nachdem wohl hunderte Flüchtlinge
darunter viele Kinder nach dem Kentern
ihres Bootes im Mittelmeer ertrunken
sind gibt es deutliche Kritik an der EU
von un- und Menschenrechtsorganisationen
deshalb klar dass der derzeitige Ansatz
der EU für das Mittelmeer nicht
funktioniere so die internationale
Organisation für Migration die Staaten
müssen gemeinsam die Lücken bei Suche
und Rettung schließen über die
Katastrophe Annette hilsenbeck
trauerbeflagungen Griechenland wo
inzwischen Angehörige derer eingetroffen
sind die auf dem unglücksboot waren der
Syrer Kasse im Abo sieht kam aus Hamburg
wo er arbeitet seine Frau war wohl mit
an Bord
ich hatte einen Antrag auf Asyl für
meine Frau gestellt in Deutschland wo
ich arbeite aber das hat sich verzögert
wir bekamen keine Genehmigung auf
Familienzusammenführung
die Frauen und bis zu 100 Kinder waren
unterdeckt es überfüllten fischerbotes
berichten Überlebende Mittwoch früh
Sankt das vor der griechischen Küste in
internationalen Gewässern
Patrouillen Boote der griechischen
Küstenwache waren zuvor zu dem desolaten
Kutter gefahren hatten nach eigenen
Angaben Hilfe angeboten diese sei
abgelehnt worden nun gibt es Kritik das
Unglück hätte verhindert werden können
was immer die Leute an Bord zur
griechischen Küstenwache oder in den
Frachtern in der Nähe gesagt haben oder
gesagt haben sollen als diesen Boot
Hilfe angeboten wurde das Boot hätte
seine Fahrt auf keinen Fall fortsetzen
dürfen
das Problem nach internationalem sehr
Recht dürfen zu Hilfe eilende nur
eingreifen wenn sie beten werden
üblicherweise wollen Schiffe die sich in
einer prekärenlage befinden ja Hilfe
haben aber wenn eine Kapitänin ein
Kapitän entscheidet wir haben keine
Notlage dann besteht auch kein Recht
anderer Schiffe hier einzugreifen und
das Schiff gegen den Willen der
Besatzung abzuschleppen oder an Bord zu
gehen
gestern Abend demonstrierten
Oppositionsgruppen in Athen gegen die
Migrationspolitik von Griechenland und
der EU 9 Männer wurden mittlerweile in
Zusammenhang mit der Tragödie
festgenommen sie sollen zu den
Schleusern gehört haben
Menschen gegen Panzer Freiheitswillen
gegen Unterdrückung dafür steht der 17
Juni 1953 in der DDR
Bauarbeiter waren die ersten die sich
gegen höhere arbeitsnaumen auflehnten
Massendemonstrationen im ganzen Land
Folgen der Junge kommunistisch gelenkte
Staat rief sowjetische Panzer um die
eigene Bevölkerung niederzuhalten
mindestens 55 Menschen starben mehr
10.000 wurden eingesperrt heute
erinnerte der Bundestag an den
Volksaufstand vor ziemlich genau 70
Jahren Andrea Maurer
17 Jahre war Siegfried Heil alt Lehrling
in den leunawerken als er sich den
Demonstranten des 17 Juni 1953 Anschluss
für bessere Arbeitsbedingungen deutsche
Einheit Demokratie mit Hilfe
sowjetischer Panzer und Soldaten schlug
die DDR den Aufstand nieder
anderthalb Jahre lang musste Siegfried
Keil ins Gefängnis der Bundespräsident
verteidigt den Freiheitskampf auch gegen
die Vereinnahmung es ist eine
fadenscheinige Lüge
wenn die Gegner unserer Demokratie wenn
Populisten und Extremisten behaupten es
sei heute genau wie damals genau wie in
einer Diktatur viele afd-abgeordnete
klatschen demonstrativ nicht der
Bundespräsident warnt heute auch vor
einer Verklärung der DDR
privates Glück schöne Momente
gab es und mag es auch in der Diktatur
geben die Erinnerung daran kann man
niemandem nehmen aber wir kennen doch so
viele Zeugnisse aus der DDR die uns vor
Augen führen dass die SED-Diktatur bis
in den letzten Winkel des Alltags der
Menschen hineinreichte der 17 Juni 1953
gilt als erster Riss in der SED-Diktatur
hunderttausende vor allem Arbeiter
lehnten sich auf gegen den Arbeiter und
Bauernstaat mehr als 50 Menschen starben
1953 und
1989 gehören zum großen demokratischen
Erbe dass die Menschen im Osten unseres
Landes errungen haben
es war ein Kampf den die Deutschen im
Westen nicht führen mussten am Ende
erheben sich alle im Parlament zu Ehren
der Aufständischen des 17 Juni 1953
[Applaus]
im Schweizer Bergdorf Brenz hatten wo
die wenigsten auf so viel Glück zu
hoffen gewagt Ende Mai mussten sie ihre
Heimat verlassen weil ein Felssturz das
Dorf bedrohte heute Nacht kam der Berg
tatsächlich herunter und am Morgen
zeigte sich wie knapp alles gut ging der
Meter hohen steinmaßen stocken kurz vor
der alten Schule das Dorf blieb
unversehrt allerdings können die
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner noch nicht
zurück weil unklar ist ob noch etwas
nachkommt
so Norbert heute Abend muss die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft über möglich mal was
liefern gegen Polen oder wir haben in 21
Länderspielen nur ein einziges Mal gegen
einen DFB-Team gewonnen aber der einzige
fußballriese Deutschland der wankt nach
den jüngsten Misserfolgen der Druck auf
Team und Trainer ist groß
sie wollen den sportlichen Engpass
überwinden Blick fordert dass die Kritik
sich an ihn richten soll und nicht an
seine Spieler
ihr könnt gerne mich kritisieren aber
bitte lass die Spieler draußen
für Flick und die Bayern Akteure kommt
es im Nationalstadion von Warschau zu
einem Wiedersehen mit dem polnischen
Topstar Robert Lewandowski
das ist ein Freundschaftsspiel aber es
geht auch ums Prestige ich habe lange in
Deutschland gespielt treffe viele
Bekannte und Freunde wieder deshalb ist
das auch ein spezielles Spiel
Lewandowski könnte die Krise des
DFB-Teams weiter verschärfen
das Duell im nations League Finale am
Sonntag lautet Kroatien gegen Spanien
nachdem sich la Rocher gestern Abend in
einem hochdramatischen Halbfinalspiel
mit zwei zu eins gegen Italien
durchgesetzt hat
Spanien feiert seine Fußballer mal
wieder Siegtor Schütze hosselu er trifft
in der 88 Minute zum Sieg gegen Italien
ein Ping Pong Tor aber vorher muss
gezittert werden Codestelle vor Ente
sieht zwar ein frühes Tor seines Teams
in der dritten Minute aber Italien
gleicht aus vom Punkt Ex bvb-stürme
giroyim mobile Italien mit Chancen Simon
im Tor mit tollen Paraden Spanien jubelt
im Finale geht Sonntag gegen Kroatien
geleitet wird das Match vom deutschen
Felix zweier
ja beim ATP Turnier in Stuttgart das
Halbfinale erreicht er siegt in zwei
Sätzen gegen den Franzosen Richard
Trauer um Radprofi Gino der Schweiz aber
gestern bei der Tour des Swiss kurz vor
Ende der Berge von der Straße abgekommen
und in eine Schlucht gestürzt heute ist
der seinen schweren Verletzungen erlegen
und gefährliche Kollision bei der Welt
Umsegelung Ocean Race nach dem Staat zur
letzten Etappe in Den Haag wird das
führende Boot elevens hour Racing von
der Gio Europa gerannt beide Schiffe
werden schwer beschädigt die Amerikaner
wollen nach Reparatur weitermachen das
gioteam gibt aber auf jetzt sind nur
noch drei Boote dabei darunter die
malizia mit Skipper Doris Hermann
Gott sei Dank keine Verletzten bei dem
Unglück
und wir schauen aufs Wetter in diesen
Tagen stellt sich die Wetterlage bei uns
um außer Sonne gibt es auch Regenschauer
und Gewitter und später wird es von
Südwesten schwül warm mehr gleich von
Katja honeffer das heute journal an
diesem Abend um 22 Uhr mit Dunja Hayali
Morgen begrüßt Sie hier mit reserin auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend endlich Regen mögen Sie
gedacht haben als es heute Nacht anfing
zu regnen und auch heute über Tag viel
noch Regen besonders hier im Nordosten
und in der zweiten Tageshälfte gesellten
sich dann Gewitter dazu
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in Brandenburg in
Niedersachsen vor allen Dingen aber auch
in Bayern und mit diesen Gewittern haben
wir es jetzt auch noch am Abend zu tun
in der zweiten Nachthälfte dann
allerdings werden die Regenschauer und
Gewitter mehr und mehr in sich
zusammenfallen im Norden bilde sich
etwas Nebel oder Dunst und im Westen ist
es klar bei einem Wind aus West
nordwestlichen Richtungen die
Temperaturen sinken auf 14 bis 9 Grad in
der Eifel wird es deutlich kälter da
geht's bis 5 Grad runter in der
Osthälfte liegen morgen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei 21 bis 26 im
Westen bei 23 bis 31 Grad und der Tag
beginnt erstmal ganz freundlich es gibt
allerdings schon erste Regenschauer hier
im Nordosten und am Nachmittag brodelt's
wieder in der Atmosphäre in Nordosten
können dann kräftigere Regenschauer und
Gewitter sich zusammenbauen am Sonntag
gibt's noch letzte Regenschauer an der
Ostseeküste und von Südwesten wird es
schwül warm und gewittrig bei
Temperaturen bis 33 Grad schönes
Wochenende